hooks et puis alien de ridley scott film
fantastique au sous titre révélateur le
huitième passager ce huitième passager
est un monstre qui va semer la terreur
dans un vaisseau spatial
on regarde un extrait c'est ce que je
peux manger quelque chose ça moi aussi
je meurs de faim on ne tient pas à
rentrer chez moi ok alors c'est la pause
n'a pas à t'inquiéter pour ça faudrait
laisser au réfrigérateur est capable de
se réveiller pour racheter aux congés
lettre la première chose que je ferai
quand le star entre chez once de bon
mais ça fait bien voir sur moi je mets
souvent dû beaucoup mieux quoi - croisés
précipite sur la nourriture comme s'il
n'y avait pas bien pour la santé que
cette nourriture nourriture qui savait
quoi je prends autant l'année
hippolyte errements si vous connaissez
la suite c'est que vous avez vu le film
mais les terrifiantes d'ailleurs on
arrête